ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Our lesson today is called
the 'Inverse Logarithm'.
And what it will do, among other
things, is give us a
very nice chance to revisit
inverse functions in general,
only now applied specifically
to the natural logarithm
function that we talked
about last time.
So I call today's lesson, as I
say, 'Inverse Logarithms'.
And to see what's coming up
here, simply recall that last
time, we invented, so to speak,
a new function called
the 'natural log of x'.
This had nothing to
do with exponents.
It was what?
This was the function whose
derivative with respect to 'x'
was '1/x' and passed through
the point (1 , 0).
That uniquely defined this
particular function.
The point being what?
That this particular function,
since the domain is for
positive 'x', '1/x'
is positive.
The curve is always rising,
which means that the function
itself must be one to one.
And because the function is one
to one, it means that the
inverse function exists.
This is no different from any
other example of forming f
inverse, given a one to one
function called 'f'.
So what we do is now,
and remember how
you invert this function.
If you want to do this thing
in slow motion, you first
rotate this through 90 degrees,
then flip it over.
If you want to do it faster, the
inverse graph of this is
the reflection of this curve
with respect to the line 'y'
equals 'x'.
In any event, if we do this, we
find that the graph of the
function 'y' equals
'inverse log x' is
this particular curve.
And notice the correspondence.
If this is the point (1 , 0) on
the log curve, the inverse
point is (0 , 1).
In other words, the inverse
log of 0 is 1.
OK.
Now, the idea is something
like this.
Just to have a review,
again, of how--
see, the punchline I want to
make for today's lesson, right
at the beginning, is that the
nice thing about studying
inverse functions is that once
you know the function of which
you're taking the inverse, you
automatically get all the
mileage you want out of
the inverse function.
Well, by way of illustration,
if the function natural log
had the usual logarithmic
property, we would suspect
that its inverse
should have the
usual exponential property.
Now what is the usual
exponential property?
The exponential function is
characterized by what?
That if you take 'f of 'x1 plus
x2'', that's 'f of x1'
times 'f of x2'.
So you think of it
in terms of the
usual exponential notation.
If you have, say, 10 raised to
the 'x1 plus x2' power, that's
the same as 10 to the
'x1' power times
10 to the 'x2' power.
In other words, if our ln
function is genuinely a
logarithmic function, we would
expect the inverse of that
function to be a genuine
exponential function.
And just to work with inverses
again, let's see if this is
indeed true.
Let's see if it's really true
that the 'inverse log of 'x1
plus x2'' is the 'inverse
log of x1' times the
'inverse log of x2'.
You see, the whole
idea is what?
Let's give these things names.
Let 'y1' be the 'inverse log
of x1' and 'y2' be the
'inverse log of x2'.
Now, since we've already
studied the natural log
function, the most natural thing
to do here is to invert
these, namely 'y1' equals the
inverse 'natural log of x1' is
the same as saying 'x1' is
the 'natural log of y1'.
And similarly, this is the same
as saying that 'x2' is
the 'natural log of y2'.
And now we add equals to equals,
and we get that 'x1
plus x2' is 'natural log y1'
plus 'natural log y2'.
But allegedly, we understand the
properties of the natural
log, because if we didn't
understand those, it would be
kind of futile to be studying
the inverse function.
What do we know about
the natural log?
We know that the 'natural
log of 'y1 times y2', by
definition of a logarithmic
function, is 'log
y1' plus 'log y2'.
In other words, 'natural log y1'
plus 'natural log y2', by
the property of being
logarithmic, is just the
'natural log of 'y1
times y2''.
And now, taking this
relationship and inverting it
to say this is the same
as saying what?
The 'inverse natural log of 'x1
plus x2'' is equal to 'y1'
times 'y2'.
And if we now observe that 'y1'
was the 'inverse natural
log of x1', and 'y2' is the
'inverse natural log of x2',
we have the result that we
claimed we would have at the
beginning here.
Now again, here's one example
where it's not the result that
I'm not interested in.
But I'm interested in showing,
again, what we meant when we
said that once we learn a new
concept, we can bring to it
all of our old knowledge.
You see, all of these things
come from our basic
definition.
Well, let's carry on
one step further.
You see, this was an arithmetic
property.
Let's see if we can get some
calculus properties about the
inverse natural log based on our
knowledge of the natural
log itself.
Well, for example, in a course
of this type, the most natural
thing to do, I guess, is given
any function, we would always
like to be able to talk about
its derivative, provided, of
course, the function
is differentiable.
So for example, a typical
question that one might ask is
find 'dy dx', if 'y' is 'inverse
natural log x'.
Again, this works the same way
as it did for the inverse trig
functions, for the inverse of
everything that we've done so
far in this course.
We start with this particular
relationship and right away
translate it into that which
we're more familiar with,
namely we translate 'y' equals
the 'inverse natural log of x'
into 'x' equals 'natural
log y'.
Now you see again, since I know
how to differentiate 'log
y' with respect to 'y', the
derivative of 'natural log y'
with respect to 'y' was
by definition '1/y'.
From this relationship
here, I can find
that 'dx dy' is '1/y'.
And knowing that 'dx dy' is
'1/y', using my inverse
function general theory that
tells me that to find the
derivative of 'y' with respect
to 'x', all I have to do is
invert the derivative of 'x'
with respect to 'y', I wind up
with the fact that 'dy dx'
is equal to 'y' itself.
In other words, the 'inverse
log x' function is
characterized by the fact that
it's its own derivative.
In other words, it's a
non-destructible type of
function with respect
to differentiation.
This is a rather powerful
property.
You see what this thing says?
It says that the derivative
of 'y' with respect
to 'x' is 'y' itself.
By the way, just as an aside, we
can do the converse of this
particular problem.
You see, we started with 'y'
equals 'inverse log x' and
showed that this particular
equation was satisfied.
Notice that if we start with
this particular equation,
starting with 'dy dx' equals
'y', separate the variables,
and lo and behold, we wind up
with 'dy over y' equals 'dx'.
And without carrying out the
details, I leave this to you,
because it is straightforward.
Notice that as we look at the
left hand side here, we
hopefully will think
immediately
of the natural logarithm.
Namely, what do we want here?
The function whose derivative
with respect to 'y' is '1/y'.
Again, you see what I'm saying
is notice that if we had
started with this particular
differential equation, we
could have shown that a
logarithm, and hence solving
for 'y' explicitly, would
have led to the
inverse logarithm also.
But at any rate, notice then
that we can find the
derivative of the inverse log
just by knowing how to find
the derivative of the natural
log itself, which is as we
expect things should be.
Again, and this is a notational
thing, we do not
use the language in general
"inverse log x."
In other words, it's quite
conventional to talk about
'inverse sine x'.
You may notice that sometimes
in the text, sometimes in my
lectures I may have used
the word 'arcsin x'.
But the general notation
is sine to the minus 1.
However, when it comes to the
natural logarithm function,
the inverse is usually
not written as
'inverse natural log x'.
It's usually abbreviated, and
let me say this, by the symbol
'e to the x'.
Now the reason I say by
the symbol is this.
If I wanted to, I can say, look,
If I've never heard of
exponents before, let this
symbol be an abbreviation for
'inverse log x'.
Does 'inverse log x' exists?
Yes, I even drew the graph of
it at the beginning of this
particular lecture.
However, again, if you are
tempted to use exponents, the
notation 'e to the x' is in
keeping in line with the idea
of our previous lecture.
I say what?
This matches the identification
of 'natural log
x' with the 'log of x'
to the base 'e'.
Remember, in our previous
lecture, we mentioned that
this particular function exists
without having to talk
about a base.
But if you wanted to identify
it with a traditional
logarithm, the base you would
have to pick is the base 'e',
where we showed that 'e' was
some number between 2 and 4.
In other words, again, it's just
like our 'dy dx' versus
'dy' divided by 'dx' and
other symbols that we
invented this way.
Namely, if I look at 'e to the
x' as being the inverse of the
natural log, or whether I look
at it as being 'e' raised to
the 'x' power, where 'e' is that
number that's someplace
between 2 and 4, I don't get
into any trouble either way
because of the natural
identification of choosing e
to be the base of my system.
But I just mention
that in passing.
Now you see, the rest
of today's lecture
will go fairly quickly.
And the reason that it will go
fairly quickly is that once
we've established what the
function is that we're talking
about, every other property of
that function is going to
follow from the principles that
we've already learned.
For example, in terms of our
new notation, since the
derivative of 'e to the x' with
respect to 'x' is 'e to
the x' itself, remember,
'e to the x' now can
be viewed as what?
'e to the x' power, or, to be on
safer grounds, if you want
to be consistent, it's just an
abbreviation for 'inverse
natural log x'.
But at any rate, if 'u' is now
any differentiable function of
'x', notice that to find the
derivative of 'e to the u'
with respect to 'x', by the
chain rule, I can say what?
It's the derivative of 'e to
the u' with respect to 'u'
times 'du dx'.
We've just shown that the
derivative of 'e to the u'
with respect to 'u' is
'e' to the 'u' again.
And therefore, the derivative
of 'e to the u' with respect
to 'x' is 'e to the
u' times 'du dx'.
By the way, this again leads to
another interesting thing
that makes integrals tough
to handle, in a way.
We've mentioned this before,
but here's another nice,
natural environment to bring
this problem up in again.
When we discussed the second
fundamental theorem of
integral calculus to show how
one actually would have to
understand areas to be able
to find a function whose
derivative was 'e to the
'minus x squared', we
mentioned, we didn't prove it,
we mentioned that there was no
familiar function whose
derivative with respect to 'x'
was 'e to the 'minus
x squared'.
So this would be a very
difficult problem to handle.
Now, let's look at
this one instead.
Let's look at integral '2x 'e
to the minus x squared' dx'.
To the untrained eye, it would
appear that this is even
messier than this.
In other words, this is just 'e
to the 'minus x squared''.
This one has 'e to the 'minus
x squared'' with a '2x'
dangling in front of it, and
that looks even tougher.
But notice that if we look
at our exponent, 'minus x
squared', the derivative, or the
differential of 'minus x
squared' is what?
It's 'minus '2x dx''.
In other words, the '2x dx' is
precisely what you need to
reduce this to the form integral
''e to the u' du'.
In other words, working this
thing out in more specific
detail, if I let 'u' equal
'minus x squared', 'du'
becomes 'minus '2x dx'', and
therefore integral '2x 'e to
the 'minus x squared'' dx'
just becomes what?
Well, the 'e to the 'minus x
squared'' just becomes 'e to
the minus u'.
And '2x dx' is just
'minus du'.
OK?
I'm sorry, 'u' is 'minus
x squared'.
'u' is 'minus x squared'.
So 'minus x squared' is 'u'.
So this becomes 'minus
e to the 'u du''.
And that, of course,
is just minus.
See, the minus will
come outside.
The integral of 'e to the u'
with respect to 'u' is
just 'e to the u'.
And since 'u' is equal to 'minus
x squared', all we're
saying is that if you
differentiate minus 'e' to the
'minus x squared', you
wind up with what?
'2x 'e to the 'minus x
squared'', the reason being
that you must multiply this by
the derivative of the exponent
with respect to 'x'.
The root of the exponent
is 'minus 2x'.
'Minus 2x' times minus
1 is '2x'.
If you want to see this in
more concise differential
notation, you see, what we're
saying is that the integral of
'e' to some power with respect
to that same power is 'e' to
that power plus a constant.
In other words, the function
that one would have to
integrate 'e to the 'minus x
squared'' with respect to to
wind up with 'e to the 'minus x
squared'' would be 'minus x
squared' itself.
And you see, now, in the next
step, since this is a true
statement, the differential
of 'minus x squared'
is minus '2x dx'.
And now you see, factoring out
the minus sign and multiplying
through by minus 1, we arrive
at the same result that we
wound up with before.
But again, this is the kind of
material that we can drill on
extensively in the exercises
in this particular unit.
The technique is what?
That the basic building block
of the so-called exponential
function, the inverse natural
log, is that when you
differentiate it, you
essentially do not destroy it.
In other words, the derivative
of 'e to the u' with respect
to 'x' is 'e to the
u' times 'du dx'.
And I thought that in closing
today's lesson, I might as
well show you a very powerful
application of this particular
result in a non-obvious
situation.
And it's something that
we call second-order
differential equations.
I've picked out here a
differential equation.
Let me just show you what I
have in mind over here.
Suppose I tell you that 'y'
is a twice-differentiable
function of 'x' that satisfies
the following identity, that
the second derivative of 'y'
with respect to 'x' minus 5
times the first derivative of
'y' with respect to 'x' plus 6
times 'y' is identically 0.
And the question is, if this
equation is to be obeyed, what
must 'y' be?
And a very interesting technique
for solving this
kind of a problem, you see, this
is called a second-order
differential equation because
the highest derivative that
appears is the second
derivative.
OK, a rather powerful
technique using the
exponential is available to us
for problems of this sort.
And the idea hinges on this.
As a trial solution, which I'll
call 'y sub t', let's try
'e to the rx', where 'r' happens
to be a constant.
You see, the whole idea is if I
differentiate 'e to the rx'
with respect to 'x', I get 'e
to the rx' back again, only
with a factor of 'r', namely the
derivative of my exponent
in this case.
See, 'r' is a constant.
The derivative of 'rx' with
respect to 'x' is just 'r'.
So notice that the first
derivative of 'y sub t' with
respect to 'x' is 'r
'e to the rx''.
The second derivative
of 'y sub t' with
respect to 'x' is what?
'r' is a constant.
I differentiate 'e to the rx'.
That brings down another factor
of 'r' and leaves me
with 'e to the rx'.
You see, the whole idea being,
notice that 'e to the rx' is a
common factor of 'y sub t', 'y
sub 't prime'', 'y sub 't
double prime''.
If I now substitute these
results back into my original
equation, look what I wind up
with. 'y double prime' becomes
'r squared 'e to the rx''.
Minus '5y prime', that's minus
'5r 'e to the rx'', plus '6y',
'6e to the rx'.
And that must equal zero.
And here's the key point.
'e to the rx' is now
a common factor.
I factor that out.
If the product of two numbers
is 0, one of the
factors must be 0.
But notice from our graph of the
exponential, the inverse
logarithm, 'e to the x', 'e to
the rx' can never be negative
and can never be 0,
in fact. 'e to the
rx' is always positive.
Therefore, if 'e to the rx' is
always positive, it must be
the other factor which is 0.
But 'r squared' minus '5r' plus
6 is not a second-order
differential equation.
It's a second-degree polynomial
equation.
It's a familiar quadratic
equation, which I can solve
quite easily.
In other words, I find what?
That 'r' must be either 2,
or 'r' must equal 3.
In other words, my claim is that
either 'e to the 2x' or
'e to the 3x' must
be a solution of
this particular equation.
Of course, we can do more with
that, which we will in a later
part of calculus, not in
this package's work.
But we're not going to study
differential equations in
great detail here.
But for our present purposes,
I think this illustrates how
one can use the fact that it's
a rather powerful structural
property when the derivative of
a function with respect to
'x' is the function itself.
By the way, as a quick check,
notice that if 'y' equals 'e
to the 2x', 'y prime' is
twice 'e to the 2x'.
'y double prime' is
'4 e to the 2x'.
And therefore 'y double prime'
minus '5y prime'
plus '6y' is what?
It's '4e to the 2x' minus '10 e
to the 2x', '6 e to the 2x'.
And that, in fact, is genuinely,
identically zero.
In a similar way, checking out
'y' equals 'e to the 3x', we
get 'y prime' is '3e to the 3x',
'y double prime' is '9e
to the 3x'.
Therefore, '9e to the 3x' minus
'15 e to the 3x' plus
'6e to the 3x' is again,
identically 0.
And again, you see what this
powerful technique is.
In general, if 'a' and 'b' are
constants, the substitution 'y
sub t' equals 'e to the rx'.
And there'll be a problem in the
exercises on this to give
you additional drill.
But that substitution transforms
the second or the
differential equation, 'y double
prime' plus 'ay prime'
plus 'by' equals 0, into an
equivalent quadratic equation,
'r squared' plus 'ar'
plus 'b' equals 0.
And you see from this equation,
using the quadratic
formula, we can find the values
of 'r' that satisfy
this, and that gives
us a couple of
solutions to the equation.
Well, at any rate, I
deliberately want this lecture
to stay short to make the
most important impact.
And that is again what?
That once we knew what the
natural log function was, and
we defined the inverse natural
log function, everything that
we wanted to know about the
inverse natural log followed
from the properties
of the log itself.
And this is basically the
lesson for today.
We will continue the discussion
of exponential
functions from a different
point of
view in our next lecture.
But until that next
lecture, goodbye.
ANNOUNCER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.